why hello everyone tonight
we begin
youtube q and a
well
basically it's a very similar to our all
access so if you enjoy what we're doing
here tonight you should head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use code dw50
don't navigate from this one go to like
open a new tab then go to dailywear.com
subscribe to code dw50 for 50
off our memberships that is the best
deal of the year so make sure that you
go do that like it ends as of three
hours from now or so eastern time so
make sure that you go check it out right
now go do it right now we answer all of
your questions here and your reminder we
do a lot of important stuff we need your
membership we need your help so here is
our full
our full-scale npr style appeal to you
you will help sponsor our investigative
team which basically shifted the grounds
in loudoun county made a big difference
in that virginia race you're going to
help us
shape the culture by picking up folks
like gina carano after they are canceled
by the left-wing culture
mavens over there
and we're going to create a new and
better culture and you give us the
wherewithal to be able to do things like
challenge divide and backs mandate on
behalf of literally 80 million americans
so make sure that you go help us out
right now by getting that membership
right now really is important and i
appreciate all the people who are
already members by the way if you
remember you normally get to ask
questions like we're going to be doing
tonight over at the all access again
code dw50 go ahead and open up a brand
new tab and make sure that the magic
happens for you sending me my phone you
know all right let's see
how is it let's see wow this is moving
soups fast okay there we go
where is the all access on daily wire
well if you're a member then you get to
see it on daily wear otherwise you can't
really see it it's sort of the thing
okay
i know you're a watchfan and collector
if you had a three watch collection for
life what would you choose oh man
are we talking the ones that i currently
own or are we talking the ones that are
sort of grail watches so if you're
talking rail watches you have to always
have like a baseline rolex submariner i
know this is very high for this is very
um
class oriented stuff right these are the
questions that people desperately love
are the questions about watches and
horology but
it would be like a rolex sub uh you
you'd probably go with a patek nautilus
like 5712 uh and
maybe a royal oak oh that's fairly
generic i like i do like lang and so on
no do i own
a lot of that stuff
i own some of that stuff we got the sub
tonight by the way we are wearing the
james bond
omega omega watch
yeah it's a nice watch okay let's see
do i watch anime no
i don't
the people are asking for the gun show
okay we're going to give you a quick
sample of the gun show but very very
quick because that's kind of our only
fans guys i mean if you actually want to
see the full gun show then you have to
become a subscriber where i get fully
not naked and basically wear these
shirts it's kind of the same thing you
just get more of that but like for
longer
can i get a hug ass blockbuster video no
you can't get a hug i don't even know
you
you creep
michael says rap is music listen to
tupac and biggie
i will stick with my perspective that
rock you know what how about this rap is
music but it is bad can i do that
you already know my argument about rap
although i will admit that my whap slaps
harder than anyone else's version of
that particular so-called song
do i think that the change in the ceo of
twitter will end with the hard crackdown
on conservative positions i think
they're already doing it i think that
that's going to become more and more
not only possible but but reality i
think they're going to start doing that
more and more at all the social media
companies at this point
unless republicans take back the house
and the senate in 2022 in which case all
these people know where their bread is
buttered and they are going to do what
they can to avoid the scrutiny of the
people in power so if you put
conservatives in power
then they might loose it up a little bit
because they are all driven by who has
the power at any given time
i appreciate that thank you yeah it is
kind of annoying that i'm that we're
together on the cloud because my kids
are already asleep we already had a
beautiful hanukkah earlier uh we lit all
the candles with all the kids my wife
got hanukkah pjs for the kids i will
tell you it was adorable they are so
cute oh my god they're just so cute
uh and uh my daughter has been begging
me for a hoverboard thingy so i got her
that i got her the one that is safest
for
medium sized children
and then i held her hands while she
attempted to balance on it it was very
cute
let's see
again remember subscribe if you're going
to subscribe and see a lot of people
asking about subscribing remember code
dw50 that runs out in like three hours
and then you're done then you miss out
on 50
what is my opinion on black hebrew
israelites they have no relationship
with hebrew or israelites so that's
pretty much my opinion i see no evidence
that they are a lost tribe i see no
evidence they know anything about hebrew
i see no evidence they know anything
about the bible they actually seem like
a radical group of kooky anti-semites
protectionism or free trade free trade
now that does not mean that you as a
free trader have to abide by
giving away the store to china what i
mean by that is that for security
reasons there are good reasons sometimes
to put security-based restrictions on
trade for example we had security-based
restrictions on trade with the soviet
union for decades that's a that's a good
thing that's not that's not a bad thing
with that said generally speaking free
trade benefits the people who engage in
it
and denying people the ability to trade
freely is a restriction of their of
their
economic rights you better have you you
should have a damn good excuse for that
other than you wish to benefit this
group at the expense of this group
pineapple on pizza believe it or not yes
but i'm gonna go even worse pineapple
and jalapeno on pizza
let's see
when is the next daily wire backstage it
is uh it is happening let's see next
week next week so stay tuned stay tuned
for that
what is my opinion on billy joel
[Music]
not a huge billy joel guy
let's see
what are my thoughts on urban planning
and zoning so
i believe that local communities should
have an awful lot of ability to regulate
the way that their lives are lived i
think there are differences in how
communities should be able to
create the living conditions under which
they under which they live so at a
national level i think the restrictions
ought to be very libertarian very very
few restrictions at the national level
simply because you have very little in
common with the people you live with at
the national level however
in your local community where you live
having a broad group of people who wish
to have restrictions on for example not
allowing a giant commercial building to
be built next door to a bunch of
residential housing that makes some
sense to me so i'm not anti-zoning in
the same way that many other people are
i will say that i think a lot of zoning
laws are badly motivated i think a lot
of zoning laws are are counterproductive
in terms of allowing for new development
and allowing for more housing to be
built but
as a person who lives in a solely
residential area i would not want
somebody opening up a
7-eleven next door and so the the
baseline idea that there should be
something terrible about zoning is i
think quite silly
people get to
living in communities that people like
to live in is not
is is a right to there is such a thing
as a communal right when it comes to
living in the sort of community that
shapes how you live because there is in
fact an interplay between the community
where you live and how you live as an
individual you need institutions in
order to live the way that you want to
live right if you want to live in a nice
suburban area where you don't have
people who are doing drugs on the street
that is going to require some zoning if
you don't want to have a porn shop next
door that requires some zoning right all
of this stuff is is perfectly legit
kamala and pete 2024
when you say we can do it i'm just
wondering who is the wii here
uh is that uh is is that like we
republicans if we can make kamal np
happen 2024 i promise you i'm i'm into
it i love it i i think that's great if
we're talking
like democrats want kamala np2024 man
enjoy
seriously like that'd be great i hope
that you uh i hope you love it
j stormy says my wife and i are moving
from utah to florida next year because
of the cost of living any advice on how
to get ready for the move
uh you're going to basically just ditch
all of your winter gear your winter gear
is no longer relevant that is rule
number one i'm not sure that i've worn a
heavy jacket here one time
in the entire time we've lived here for
over a year
um let's see if somebody's asking if
desantis ran for president 2024 who
would be a good running mate um
tom cotton from arkansas tim scott maybe
again your periodic reminder because
we're doing something special tonight if
you wish to
if you wish to
get a membership for half off dw50 time
is running out
hans says ben do you have any thoughts
on the increase of talk around splitting
the country do i think that's a
realistic solution uh it seems to me not
particularly realistic because
there's still an interest in like it
depends who's doing the splitting if if
california wanted to split off from a
republican government
i think there's a better shot that
that's realistic than if texas and
florida want to split off from a
democratic government simply because the
democrats are never going to allow those
resource-rich states to simply leave and
exactly who gets to leave with the 1.2
million person federal army and the
attendant nuclear weapons exactly
more likely what you see is a is a
devolution of authority to the local and
state level which is what the founders
proposed in the first place
why do i hate vaccines and mask mandates
i i like vaccines i don't like vaccine
mandates because i think that they are a
violation of your ability to make
choices about your own life and and i
also think that they are unnecessary
given the fact that the vaccines are
effective against hospitalization and
death
and we are not going to return immunity
that is the lesson of delta there is no
herd immunity in the in the future at
all it is going to become endemic so
that means that the the belief that you
require vaccine mandate is foolish
what kind of cars do i have nothing
fancy
i have family cars
do i ever plan to speak at clemson
university i believe i've spoken at
clemson in the past if not i'd be happy
to speak at clemson
so i think the educational system needs
a change it needs a massive change
because the educational system is a
massive boondoggle the educational
system
is largely designed for credentialism it
is not designed toward educating people
toward a career uh and um and
unfortunately it's a way of getting
people hundreds of thousands of dollars
into debt while providing them really no
upward trajectory in many cases there's
a recent study that came out regarding
the degrees and and whether you are
likely to actually out earn the cost of
a degree and about one-third of people
who are currently in the degree program
who graduate are not going to out-earn
the cost of the degree that is not
counting all the other people who drop
out who obviously aren't even going to
receive the degree
see
kagan says i'm 15 and broke how can i
help i'll just stay in school and do
your best and get good grades
and then
and then fight the man man fight the
system
was speechless better than the
authoritarian moment no nothing michael
moss has ever done will ever be as good
as anything i do
the worst thing i do will be better than
the than the best thing that michael
moles ever does that is the answer
would i ever consider running for office
why or why not okay the why not is
really easy because then you actually
have to be
a politician which sucks you have to
spend a lot of time raising money you
have to hang out with other politicians
and you have to compromise your
principles that's literally the job i'm
not blaming people who take the job but
that is the job
why because sometimes you can make an
awful lot of difference
would i do it right now absolutely not
you know if there might be a point when
i do it like
here's the good news
average age of people who are running
for president now is like i don't know
89 i'm 37 so i have about five decades
to make up my mind
how can i convince people from other
states that florida is good and not just
a place for crazy people okay the reason
that people think that florida is a
place for crazy people is because
florida actually has excellent
transparency laws so florida does a
really good job reporting all of its
crime stories and so that's why you see
a lot of florida man says okay florida
man does florida man does this go okay
florida man is just every person in
every state if you had vermont with his
good trans is sort of number one high
population but number two
transparency rules with regard to
reporting you get a bunch of crazy
vermont man stories as well
and yeah we have a lot of crazy florida
people here that is true
what is my favorite band um
the one that i end up playing
it's varied for a while i will say right
now my kids are very into some
they're into some of the uh kind of
newfangled jewish music so shapiro
schwecki but
uh i'm gonna go
you know all-time classics i'm gonna i'm
gonna go like doobie brothers i really
enjoy doobie brothers
i was indoctrinated by my parents into
doobie brothers
how much can i bench i've had this
question before uh i believe that the uh
so again i don't really bench very often
i think my my personal max is like 205
or was 205 when i was doing it a little
more often but i i don't know what it
would be today
i'm more of a do a lot of pull-up guys
as opposed to bench a lot
whenever i give numbers on on how i work
out what's funny is it always breaks
down into two categories people who are
like you suck and you're really weak and
people like that's kind of impressive
and the answer is probably in between
it's not all that impressive and i'm not
super crappy at it but i'm not like
super great at it either
what is my favorite food ravioli ravioli
is the greatest of all foods ravioli is
unbelievable it is literally a noodle
that is filled with something delicious
why are we doing this on youtube today
uh we're doing this on youtube today as
kind of a
favor to all of our fans because we have
a lot of people out there who watch the
show every single day and they never get
to see what an all access is like and as
i mentioned
i'm like joe biden here i'm like falling
apart as i mentioned earlier if you like
this sort of stuff if you want better
access to to see what it's like behind
the scenes here at daily wire and hang
out with us then you should go become an
all access member right now dw50 is the
code click on the link open a new tab
and then get that dw50 code and uh and
you can get a membership right now
for fifty percent off by the way do i
like anton katz's music yeah i do i
enjoy eight times his music i i he was
actually a high school classmate of mine
i'm on one of his early albums
what about the maxwell trial i haven't
seen any revelations yet if i see any
revelations i'll be more than happy to
to
report upon them
what are my thoughts on hassan um
i don't have lots of thoughts on hassan
i did a segment on him
fairly recently uh i i have to say that
i haven't found his his arguments all
that impressive i mean he's built
himself a nice following uh and i i find
it ironic that he's able to to be this
open socialist who's constantly making
excuses for spending extraordinary
amounts of money on himself that's a
that seems to be one of the nice things
about socialist even stalin had a dasha
how tall am i i am five nine as proved
in my last speech when a person actually
got up in the audience
i asked how tall i was told me i was
five five i said how tall are you he
said five nine i said come on up here
you can go watch the clip it's pretty
funny
ben favorite author uh favorite fiction
author
like all around probably mark twain all
right but
you'd have to go by individual books i
like a lot of steinbeck i i like a lot
of american authors love dostoevsky on
the on the russian side um
man i do like ray bradbury a lot i think
he's underrated he's actually so popular
that he's become underrated
i can tell you what's on my my
nightstand right now in terms of reading
so i've been reading a lot of philosophy
recently so just read some robert george
read some joseph razz
i'm reading some michael oakshot uh i've
been reading on the on the
sports side i just read a great book by
joe posnowski about the the top 100
players in baseball history which is
super fun
i
am reading on the fiction side a sci-fi
book that the name escapes and it's
called utopia it was recommended by a
friend of the family and another one
by robin hobb is that name of the person
so some fantasy kind of stuff and and
then i have anthony dore's new book but
that thing is like a book it's like a
door stop that thing it's like no pun
intended it's it's this thick and so it
takes a a long uh
uh it takes a major commitment to start
on that one
what do i order a taco bell the water
since nothing is kosher
how old am i i am 37 years old
who is the worst president ever and why
joe biden is making a real case for it i
mean it's i'd be hard pressed not to go
woodrow wilson because he did begin the
administrative state it was under
wardrobe so we began to ramp up the
income tax we entered world war one
which may or may not have been a good
decision i think probably a bad decision
and uh or at least arguably a bad
decision and um we also put in place
sedition acts to target political
opponents
and he was a massive racist who helped
to rein to reinstate and and forward
segregation so you're hard-pressed to
overcome woodrow wilson in terms of
terrible presidents uh other candidates
for worst presidents ever usually they
include james buchanan honestly a little
unfair to buchanan because we were
headed for civil war before buchanan and
that's not saying he was a good
president he wasn't but but was he like
the worst ever i doubt i think probably
the shortlist goes like
biden
obama
carter
wilson i think wilson is the pretty
pretty good consensus pick fdr lbj has
to be up there aside from the civil
rights act which you know granted major
thing in his favor at least except for
the provisions dealing with private
businesses which i had serious
reservations about
the rest of his tenure was just a
garbage heap
do i have a favorite podcast that i
listen to so i listened to a couple of
podcasts that review shows like
succession which i have been enjoying i
will say that i'm enjoying succession uh
and um and other podcasts i listen to um
let's see i'll tell you right now
so
i i enjoy the
uh the
commentary
podcast uh i enjoy i mean i'm talking
aside from from our typical daily
podcast i enjoyed the commentary podcast
i listen to the rewatchables the sub
beacon podcast is fun glenn lowry has a
fun podcast uh barry weiss her podcast
is really fun that's aside from all the
stuff we do like morning wire or walsh
or or
or
uh candace or i'm not gonna mention
knowles because i'm not sure i enjoy
that one
do i believe that people outside the
faith of judaism can reach heaven of
course so judaism is a religion that
says that you can reach heaven without
having to be jewish uh the basic rules
are that you have to
there they're basically seven rules
they're called the noahide laws under
judaism and people who are not jewish
can get to heaven if they fulfill these
seven basic rules and they are very
basic it's things like no blasphemy
established courts of law no murder no
no sexual
peccadillos uh or sexual sins uh no no
thieving
i.e kidnapping you have to establish
courts of law and uh and no eating the
flesh of living animal those are the
seven if you do that you are good to go
so that's a pretty low baseline i feel
like
no crowder i mean well i don't know why
you came here if you're looking for
crowder if you want to see a crazy
person who's randomly wrestling a
homeless guy then then head on over
crowder's channel
do i ever feel pressured to compromise
on my morals in my profession not really
i i
i
pick this profession specifically
because i get to talk about my morals
all the time which is fun one of the
reasons why i think i might have trouble
going into practical politics now that
doesn't mean you can't be a moral person
to be in practical politics i think you
just have to acknowledge openly that
when you are making a compromise you are
in fact strained from particular
principles
again your your
reminder every 10 minutes we do this
every single week like multiple times a
week all of our hosts we'll get together
with you every single night we have one
of our hosts who gets together with you
and you become an all access member at
daily wire all you have to do is head on
over to daily wire right now this is the
best deal of the year it is today cyber
monday it ends in like two and a half
hours so this is your last chance code
dw50 for 50 off
can i give you advice on how to debate
well i'm excited to see you i'm 13 and
very interested in politics i appreciate
that uh so
honestly the biggest thing about
debating is that you have to actually
listen to what the other person is
saying most people spend so much time
when they are debating
trying to think of what they say next
that they forget to actually listen to
what the person is saying usually the
person you're talking to gives you the
ammunition that you require in order to
debunk the argument or in order to
take their argument and and examine it
more closely when you examine the
premises that people use in their
arguments that is usually the best way
to get to the deepest part of the
argument and the part that's the most
interesting as well so you really have
to sit and listen to what the other
person is saying it's a skill that has
to be cultivated
my thoughts on a news platform that can
actually be trusted honestly i think
daily wire is pretty good at this we are
conservative but we make pretty clear
what's fact and what's opinion
chris says i notice you don't show your
family and posts you've made a strategic
effort to protect your family from the
spotlight absolutely so there are
thousands and thousands and thousands of
pictures of me online my parents my my
parents and my kids and my wife were
constantly going out to different places
but when people ask if they can take
pictures and thank god virtually all the
time when people approach they're very
nice i i always say
the people will say your kids can be in
the picture and always be like nope my
kids are not in the picture so um my
kids are not public figures my wife is
not a public figure
all you need to know about her is that
she is a doctor and also super really
hot those are really the two facts that
i think are relevant uh and other than
that
yeah i mean you'll get all the other
relevant facts about my kids that i feel
like telling you about as aspects of
their personality but they're not public
figures what is my opinion on austrian
economics i consider myself a devotee of
uh viennese economics like frederick
hayek and ludwig von mises i tend to be
more
austrian in my approach to economics
than chicago school
what do i think of the disabled dislike
button on youtube yeah i don't
understand why uh it's weird i don't
really i don't really think that that
makes a lot of sense it's uh it's
confusing to me what happens if you
don't like something
can i make gaming videos first i would
have to learn what a game is and how to
play one again i'm like an
eight-year-old man i live in south
florida and i don't play video games
uh the hopeful astronaut says i'm 14
want to become an entrepreneur what
advice do you have you seem to be pretty
good at it um
my first advice is that you just have to
jump in and try things and you're going
to fail a lot but every time you fail
you learn so my business partner jeremy
boring and i this is like the third
business that we started so we started a
business where he he was making videos
for folks you go back and watch them he
was making these scribing videos for
encounter videos and he was working with
prageru then he had he had something
called declaration entertainment that
predated me but i helped him out with it
a little bit
then we were truthful and then finally
we did daily wire
you learn more about your business you
learn what you're good at you know what
your business partners are good at you
learn what the market wants and when you
do all of that then you can eventually
create a product that is fit for market
and you learn how to handle yourself too
do i ever carry a gun if not what do you
think about it i'm not going to tell you
whether i carry on
i'll just say that i'm surrounded by
people with guns at all times which may
or may not include me
when i debate aoc i don't know last time
i asked about it she accused me of cat
calling her which was a weird flex by
her considering that i'm an orthodox jew
is taiwan a country yes taiwan is a
country and it is not china
do i invest in crypto yes uh i i do have
some money invested in crypto uh a not
insignificant amount of money invested
in crypto some in bitcoin and some and
ethereum and i have done unbelievably
well on it i am a fan of crypto
what are my thoughts on climate change
are humans damaging to our earth's
climate yes climate change is happening
yes human activity contributes to global
warming no it's not a crisis no we
shouldn't be panicking no we shouldn't
destroy the global economy because we
are afraid that over the course of the
next 100 years there's going to be some
change in the climate
that's the short answer human beings are
great at adaptation and really terrible
at mitigation meaning that we are very
good at adapting to changing
circumstance we are not particularly
good at developing technologies not on
the basis of market fundamentals and
competitive economics but on the basis
of i wish that we had a product that did
x even if it was super expensive and we
got rid of our lifestyles and we all
went back to the forest that ain't gonna
happen get over it
thoughts on hockey so i love hockey it's
super fun i just didn't grow up with it
i didn't spend a lot of time with it so
i it doesn't come naturally to me i wish
i were more into it my son's five so
maybe i can get him into it
steve says hey ben would you ever
interview cal rittenhouse and have him
on the show yeah why not
let's see
who are the best presidents of all time
washington lincoln coolidge
reagan
um
i think the list of really good
presidents is very is very very short um
other than that i i did do a
presidential ranking list at one point
but i think that they're really only two
that are clear a's and then you have a
couple of b's and b's are like coolidge
and reagan
and then you have a crap lotuses and in
the seas you have people like harry
truman and george w bush and um
and
maybe trump what was weird about trump
is that trump is like on policy
a
b to a b to maybe an a minus on some
stuff and on rhetoric he was just a
complete disaster and it cost him his
re-election and i understand there's so
many people who love all the stuff that
trump had to say and listen i loved some
of it too some it was hysterically funny
there's never been a funding our human
being who's been president of the united
states that's for sure but the fact that
he couldn't keep his mouth shut is why
he was not re-elected and that is
devastating for the country it's
devastating for his agenda and it's
honestly it's a real problem
i would like like one ounce one ounce of
ability to to use the filter between his
brain and his mouth and he'd still be
president of the united states
teddy roosevelt uh not a huge ted
roosevelt fan i'm gonna put teddy in
that c category
i i don't think that teddy was a great
president his trust busting was not good
his uh his progressive view toward
administrative government was not good
not a huge teddy fan
what is the behind the uptick in
organized group shoplifting the uptick
is specifically because of
the lack of policing of crime period end
of story if you tell people you're not
going to
prosecute shoplifting it turns out
they're going to shoplift
and they're going to
exploit holes in the market obviously
aaron says do i know jordan peterson is
what do i think of his opinions in
political affiliation uh jordan and i
are friends we you should check out the
multiple interviews that we've done with
one another i think jordan is wonderful
i think it does a lot of terrific work
for the for the world and particularly
for young men who are looking for
guidance
design sister trump 2024 uh i've said
before desantis i think that he's an
extraordinarily capable chief executive
of state i think that he's done a
wonderful job here in the state of
florida i think he is very militant when
it comes to the media and he knows his
stuff inside and out do i play piano i
do not at least not be on the first few
bars of the moonlight sonata
have i ever been to buffalo new york uh
yes i have actually actually a good
buffalo story okay so my wife and i
we visited buffalo
and um this is right after we were
engaged and we visited buffalo new york
to visit niagara falls and it was the
dead of winter this was a mistake we
went like right around new year's and it
is damned cold it is so cold in buffalo
at that time of year
so we stay at this hotel
and
and at this hotel
we there is a um a person behind the
counter it's like a holiday inn
yeah we didn't have tons of money at
that point um and um we stayed this
holiday inn and this
and the person behind the counter is
like would you like a limousine to
niagara falls we're like sure
sounds great
so we go uh we we you know kind of go
dump our stuff and then the limousine
shows up and limousine is obviously
somebody who gives a kick back to the
guy at the front desk because the person
who drives up is
this bizarre looking cd character
driving a white limousine from probably
1975 with a red velvet interior upon
which many dirty deeds have likely been
done and we get into this limousine and
we are in buffalo
and uh we have no food like none
and the only food that we have is a bag
of bagel chips that we picked up at the
airport we're sitting there and we're
munching on our bag of bagel chips which
is our soul sustenance in buffalo new
york in the dead of winter and this guy
turns around
and he
goes can i have some of those
and we're like we're in the middle of
nowhere we don't know who you are and we
have no alternative car available so
we're like okay
he starts munching on our bagel chips so
things are already very uncomfortable
then he says so you guys just got
engaged like yep and we're really
excited about it he's like well let me
just tell you i'm married six times like
okay he goes well let me just tell you
as a man who's been married six times
there's only one thing one piece of
advice i would give you
keep the spark alive
and um then we got out of the car
and he says do you want me to stick
around take you back and we're like no i
think we will find our own way back
thank you sir
goodbye and to this day my wife and i
call that guy the mayor of buffalo
can we get a gun show you already missed
it again if you want the gun show on a
regular basis you got to be it's like
only fans over there at all access
except with me wearing lots of layers of
clothing and occasionally flexing my
biceps
what is my favorite movie of all time
probably the lives of others love the
lives of others by the way it started
wheel of time you guys started wheel of
time yet i'm enjoying the wheel of time
i like it although uh i do love this
sort of random randomly woke inserts
those are kind of funny it's like oh
yeah a threesome okay that's kind of a
weird reference in episode four
strange
you know there's like these kind of
weird little asides where like i feel
like that's not super in the spirit of
the book but
okay
all right i guess
i do take i do take tv recommendations
from our crowd at all access by the way
and again a reminder dw50 is the code
head on over to our subscribe page and
get your 50 off deal today it is now two
and a half hours until that is over
for the year
what is my favorite nolan movie um
someone says inception no so i am the
rare person who says
um interstellar i love interstellar i
think interstellar is great
i know
but it's a fantastic fantastic score
excuse me my kids are all sick right now
by the way
like all three of them all three of them
were home from school have you so we had
this thanksgiving weekend it was just
great i spent a lot of time with the
kids and then as all parents know with
small children you have this long
thanksgiving weekend spend tons of times
with the kids and then you're like you
know what it's time for me to go back to
work and the kids go back to school so
we're ready ready to go
sunday afternoon
all three are sick and so all three of
them were home today and dad it was
daddy duty after work today so yeah
favorite character in star wars probably
obi-wan
although
i do do for my kids all of the
impressions of the different voices
you
will learn
a little yoda there for y'all
got some chewbacca
which also
it's it's good to get these voices you
know sort of good to go because they
come in handy like when we have last
year the race between biden and trump
and i said it was chewbacca versus the
swedish chef which it kind of was it was
like trump's like
and then you'd have bite and be like
[Music]
beautiful
misa
as we get uh later at night uh the
voices get uh more and more bizarre by
the way
i do take requests on all access for
those uh for the bizarre voices favorite
thomas solo book uh disparity and
discrimination is a really good one uh
the uh what is um
knowledge and decisions is pretty
fantastic
do i like stephen crowder yes we are
friends
ben doing star wars noise is the best oh
you have no idea
[Music]
i like uh i do like your reactions where
you guys randomly i just realized that
this is all bizarre yes it is
do the cheek singing thing again no no
no i'm gonna save that for uh for behind
the paywall you're going to have to
access that that is a special life skill
i can actually play tunes upon my cheeks
i'll just give you a i'll give you a
hint of it
okay here's here's a little bit of a
hint see if you can name that tune you
ready
is this a ventral wash this is not an
insurance watch as i mentioned before
this is the uh omega bond watch
how do i find the time to do all of
these things
um
the uh which things you know learn to
play music on my cheeks
it just it comes naturally it's a life
skill what can i say
do i imagine that bacon tastes good i
imagine so people love it
yeah you guys got it smoke on the water
all right
let's see
whap no you can't see this is the thing
about rap there's no way to actually do
the tune of lab because it has no tune
okay um where is my ex chair it's at the
office is it like the office to you this
is like one of my bedrooms all my kids
are asleep
are my hands bigger than marco rubies
who little america little america
unbelievable tiny hands little america
you know what they say
how do you come out to your girlfriend
as a conservative you say that you want
to spend the rest of your life being a
monogamous religious person who lives a
responsible lifestyle and then you see
how she takes that
favorite mexican food
um burritos are spectacular
chicken tacos are pretty awesome too
beef tacos that's great
do i ever get tired of talking
absolutely i'm so tired of me right now
i can't even tell you
but we're here together man we will
suffer through this thing together we'll
get through it
do i use raycons i do i do use raycons
r-a-y-c-o-n
ben go check it out right now
what are my views on the war on drugs um
largely ineffective
i think the war on drugs uh has been
rather a large failure
and it and while i
understand that the war on hard drugs
might be
necessary the war on marijuana has
obviously been a gigantic failure
just because i want government to be
able to do a thing doesn't mean the
government's actually capable of doing a
thing
what is a dish my wife makes that i
secretly dislike well if i answer this
question
nothing secret about it so my wife makes
a couple of dishes that the kids really
like but that i just am not a huge fan
of she makes these uh these kind of
turmeric based lima beans and um
they're actually pretty good but i'm a
little allergic to them my wife doesn't
my math is pretty great in the sense
that well in most senses but also the
sense where if i tell her i don't like a
particular food she just won't repeat
making it
do i like sinatra i love sinatra
favorite character in lord of the rings
uh strider
how's hanukkah been so far it's been
fantastic thank you for asking my kids
are super into it this year again my
wife got them happy hanukkah pj's is so
cute tonight oh my gosh and
they've really been enjoying it they
know the whole story of hanukkah
um
you know south florida is a great place
to celebrate hanukkah so there's stuff
going on nearly all the time so it's
super fun
and and also i i will say we we here at
the shapiro household take kamala
harris's perspective on hanukkah
extraordinarily seriously i definitely
need to hear from her i think that that
kamala harris has the best perspective
on hanukkah because of course she's
married to a jewish guy and her
perspective is joy and light and light
and joy and
in the middle of that one just gonna
turn into biden
list of all time people i want to debate
i've offered burning i've offered aoc
kamala for president no
that'd be silly
thoughts on in his cancer freedom i love
that he uh that he renamed himself
freaking that's awesome
did i eat any did i eat any lot because
yeah my wife makes great lakkas i was
not a fan of latkes until i met my wife
my wife makes fantastic a lot because
they're so good next time here i'll give
you guys the recipe
how was my golf game not particularly
good although the last time i played
i i the last couple holes i buried two
holes in a row i literally picked up the
ball and i walked off the course i was
like i'm done
waffles waffles or pancakes i'll go
waffles it's like a pancake but it's
able to hold things it's fantastic it's
both useful and delicious
although a nice thin pancake you know
like when it's like crispy around the
edges with the butter
man carbs are just great
josh says currently in hospital with
pregnant wife advice for me the dad
during labor well first of all you
should be able to take a paternity leave
at least four times as long as your
wife's my turn to leave this is what
i've learned from our current secretary
of transportation obviously you're the
one doing the real suffering here
but aside from that
the number one piece of advice put down
your phone so first
time my wife gave birth
i will say that she was in labor forever
we went in and she was in labor for like
25 hours
not hard labor the hard labor was like
two hours at the end but the the actual
labor labor was like 25 hours because
the water broke they're like we have to
stay here we have to take pitocin and
they might say i mean her because she
did all the work and um and so for like
25 hours my god i'm so bored it's so
boring and it is it's super boring
you're sitting there and you're just
waiting for something to happen and
she's sitting there trying suffering and
so you're like okay i'm gonna sit here
i'll do some work watch some tv you know
read a book no no no no no no bad move
terrible bad move you are there to
suffer along with her i learned this
because my child number two in child
number three i was very present now i
will admit the labors were a lot shorter
by child number three it was like a
three hour labor and that was great that
was perfect that's exactly the amount of
time that my attention span could take
but it is definitely uh it is definitely
a thing that you cannot be playing
around on your phone i was like why are
you on your phone i'm like because
nothing's happening she's like but i'm
giving birth like not right now you're
not like stop arguing with me i'm
literally having a baby that's like yeah
that's you have a point
can i give hudson a shout out done
michaela says i have a film company we
tried to reach out to you we love you
you can try it one more time and let me
know that you reach out to me here
favorite florida team
uh i'm gonna go
with the marlins because that would make
me the only fan of the florida marlins
so i'm automatically their best fan it's
like me and derek jeter
keep the fits that i want that shirt
well we have a merch store glad you
asked get your special deals on
everything at the merch store
you get special deals if you're a member
but to become a member code dw50 50 off
time is running out you now have two
hours and 17 minutes before it's all
over for you
has anyone ever tried to knock off my
yamaka how does this down so well it
stays on as well because it has little
clips on it
you hear that that right there is the
sound of security heaven's security
clipped keep us little little
unsolicited ad there for our friends
over at eclipse keep us
happy birthday to friend eric
let's see
brian wants a shout out you got it dude
so i play chess
a little bit i kind of go through spates
of playing chess so what happens is that
i'll do something and it's really fun
and then i'll be like oh i really want
to get into this and so i do it for like
a few weeks and then i'm like do i
really have the time to dedicate to
getting really good at this and the
answer is no so i just kind of stay
mediocre at it i feel that way about
golf i feel that way about
about chess as well like to really get
good at it you have to dedicate
extraordinary amounts of time you have
to memorize all of the openings
and you have to you have to
know how to counter all of them and i
want to be good at things but i don't
want to dedicate the time to be good at
things so i'd rather just dedicate the
time to things that i think are
important
which which you know i guess that's kind
of a bad way to be
maybe i'd enjoy life more if i really
dedicated some time to some of this
stuff but honestly every time i play
chess for a long period of time i'm like
maybe i should really spend a lot of
time
you know i spend more time reading in
writing frankly
can i do my pelosi impression nancy
pelosi
nancy pelosi
well she's making stock trades right now
based on her regulatory strategy
but it's not corrupt because she's a
democrat
as those dentures moving around right
there am i planning on visiting israel
in the near future will they let anyone
in ever
ever
it's ridiculous
have i ever trained in the martial arts
no i've trained in the hiring people to
to
kill people who threaten me uh have ever
trained in the martial arts i did a
little bit of krav maga a few years back
i can't say i got very advanced at it i
really should is the truth
it seems like a really good skill set
do i play any instruments besides violin
not well
can someone become jewish or you have to
be born jewish
just curious don't want to be jewish
yeah you know
that's good because i'd have to try to
dissuade you that's actually the jewish
law i'm not allowed to try and recruit
you to judaism
but yes you can convert to judaism why
florida over texas uh the jewish life
here is uh is more well established i
will say
that's a big thing
um do i own bitcoin yeah as i said
earlier
favorite gun i do have a rifle from bcm
from
um
bravo company manufacturing that is a
very nice piece
so i think crypto will take over i think
that centralized governments will will
work their hardest to prevent crypto
from taking over
and uh and because of that i think it's
going to end up as more of a repository
of value or a creative way of for
example doing contracts then it's going
to be like the main method of people
transferring money
across you know the economy
lovely windows you have there thank you
it is it is a great window
do i speak hebrew yes but not amazingly
well
am i let's see
former democrat says i made you become a
republican i appreciate that thank you
a lot of requests for the gun show again
you missed it it was very brief tonight
you have to be a member in order to make
that happen greta thunderbird impression
go
how dare you how dare you
you adverts and the way that you attempt
to run our lives you don't care you
don't get you pretend to care but you
don't care let me dance dance to rick
astley i'm going to dance to rick i
don't know things but i was once young
even though already over 18. again that
was the rule okay once she was 18 i can
do my impression of her as much as i
damn well please
what is my favorite sport to watch in
person baseball on tv
still basketball although i have to say
i haven't watched basketball really
since uh since the blm of it
well i ever come to new jersey to speak
maybe
do i talk to my kids about politics
occasionally occasionally it's more like
a values thing they'll ask me about
values and then i'll talk to them about
values so if they say things like they
hear at school about biden i'll be like
well you know
let's not talk about biden let's talk
about you know what he's doing and
whether it's good or bad
i think it's more important to teach my
kids about that than you know biden is a
human
am i a mets fan and i'm a white sox fan
what is my second favorite movie shen
bapiro
uh my my second favorite movie hmm
the lord of the rings trilogy probably
how much sleep do i get not as much as i
need uh probably i'm averaging i would
say probably about
six and a half to seven a night i really
need eight
and that's because i'm just going to bed
too late
and my ashkenaziers farty i'm ashkenaz
my wife is farty i read the illustrated
man by bradberry of course
what is my view on the nephilim in uh in
the book of bereishis okay so the
nephilim you'll remember from the book
of genesis it talks about how
this is the days of the nephilim the
mighty men
of yore basically and uh the and they
were cohabitating with the with the
daughters of men
and god didn't like this is one of the
reasons god didn't like things and
decided it's flood time okay so i think
that this language the language with
regards to nephilim is specifically
designed to be a rip on the class-based
rulership of the old world so nifilm in
hebrew means not thought it comes from
the rubena fall which means to fall to
fall like the fallen
the way that rulers were described
in in ancient
literature is as god-like characters
they're literally gods right if you read
mesopotamian descriptions of the kings
very often they're described as gods so
i think the idea here in the bible is
the rulers were mistreating the common
women and god didn't like it
uh so i think that their their attempts
to kind of turn that into magical like
their their fallen angels and all i
don't think that's right
have i ever been in the netherlands uh
only for a stopover i'd like to spend
more time there
favorite story of moses um
i mean the whole thing's pretty
spectacular isn't it
but the favorite story of moses probably
i would say the greatest heroic move of
moses is when he's approached by god
after the jews sin with the golden calf
and god says you know what i'm just
gonna get rid of this nation i'm making
a nation out of you he says no you made
a promise you're gonna keep the promise
it's a pretty incredible moment
when i come to indiana of course i love
indiana and yet it's great
i i would
sp delaware absolutely all of these
what are my thoughts on a war with china
i don't think that it's in either
country's interest that doesn't mean
that we should be
cow towing to china that we should be
making room for them to be as terrible
as they are
i an islamophobe no i'm not an
islamophobe i've said a thousand times
on my program that i do not evaluate
people's religions on the basis of their
text because i'm not an expert in their
texts
what i will do is evaluate how
constituents of a particular religion
behave and even then
that is not a referendum on the religion
per se
it's a referendum on the group of people
who are practicing that particular
religion so
we've had many moderate muslims reformed
muslims on the program
uh i've i've defended the right of
for example ilhan omar i think he's just
a despicable human being to wear hijab
in congress i think that
as a person who wears weird religious
headgear i'm all in favor of people
being able to wear you know headgear
representing their religion
that
i've failed to see how any of that is
islamophobic i am
across the board terrorism phobic and i
am across the board
yeah
complete fundamentalism phobic so
take that as you may
usually the video people use in defense
of the idea that islamophobic is a video
in which i actually just read statistics
from pew global research about whether
there is a tiny radical muslim minority
or whether a large number of muslims
globally believe radical things those
are those are pole statistics i don't
know what to tell you that is not a
referendum on islam is a religion it's
not a referendum on certain practices
practices of islam nor does it make you
islamophobic disciples
of muslims by the way
best book a father could read aside from
the bible
i'm gonna go off the board here for the
chip hilton series this is one of my
dad's favorite books growing up and i
think it really shaped how he thought
about the world about the nature of
virtue and heroism they're great see if
you can grab the originals by claire b
aaron says i'm able to afford that dw
membership now because of the discount
thanks ben i appreciate it go get your
dw
membership right now like now is the
time again you have like
now two hours left the time is running
out code dw50 to make the magic happen
for yourself
yeah i see some people recommending
tunnel twins i've seen some people here
recommending what would danny do these
are all good books for kids for sure
top five favorite books you really have
to go genre by genre i've been putting
out those lists at daily wire by the way
again readers pass kind of stuff so
another pitch for the membership right
there
how do i explain god to children without
confusing them uh i explained that god
is the being that lies behind the logic
of the universe who loves you and cares
about what you do at the same time
how much did i say by moving to florida
oh large large quantities of money
have i ever accidentally eaten pork um
i want to say yes i think maybe i was
eight and i was over at my cousin's
house and they were having some sausage
on the pizza and i had no idea what it
was i remember it being tasty
favorite pistol why'd you have a smith
and watch a nine millimeter so i'll go
with that
what is my opinion on oxygen pro pro
oxygen
how was harvard law school i enjoyed
harvard law i really did i thought that
it was surprisingly open-minded or at
least i found enough professors who are
open-minded to have some fun chats and
and some fun arguments i i really liked
it it's a lot of very high acute people
talking about interesting topics so long
as they're not woke jackasses
what is my favorite biblical story in
general hmm
honestly the whole tale of saul and
david is just fascinating to me it's
just riveting stuff
um
the story is the the story of jacob is
really interesting
i love so much but it really is quite
beautiful it's quite a beautiful book
do i believe in intelligent design well
if by intelligent design do i believe
that there is a creator of the universe
who stands behind natural processes yes
have i ever reached a professional level
with the violin uh
it depends on me by professional could i
play like last chair in a decent
orchestra probably would i be like the
the guy who is soloing with the
orchestra no i gave it up too early for
that
favorite mark brothers movies duck super
night at the opera my kids were watching
mark's brothers today it's pretty great
okay like two more questions and then i
must and then too bad i must go
well i do a debate with michael knowles
on libertarianism that'd be a weird
debate considering that i'm not fully
libertarian so i'm sort of libertarian
in terms of how i think about
what i think government is good at and
what government is capable of doing on
the federal level on a local level i'm
much more conservative and libertarian
what is the most useless skill i have
well i it's hard to get more useless
than being able to play songs on my
cheeks um whistling really well is is a
really useless skill
those ones are probably it
okay final question we'll give it and
give an extra
would i rather act in a new star wars
movie or a new lord of the rings movie
well um i'll go lord of the rings
because i think that they've botched
star wars beyond all recognition
alrighty folks well we have reached the
end of tonight's q and a if you liked
this if you really enjoyed it go check
out the all access we do this every
single week every week
without fail you can get that code dw
right now code dw50 for 50 off time is
running out on that best deal of the
year two hours left before it expires it
is done tonight so don't think about it
just go do it
i promise you'll enjoy it and and help
us
keep fighting because that's really what
we do join the fight join dw dw50 use
that code click on over and make the
magic happen for yourself have a
wonderful evening and happy hanukkah